welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your house definition and like a bow of
Hell named Lucille negan is on the run
episode 4 felt like a non-stop onslaught
that slowly escalated the stakes and
showed just how difficult that it is to
survive in the land of the undead and it
ended on a pretty big cliffhanger that
has a lot of fans excited throughout
this video I'm gonna be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the latest episode as well as what we
can take from the ending there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch episode 5 yet then
I highly suggest that you turn off now
that's your last chance to back out and
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into the breakdown
previously on The Walking Dead Zeke
doesn't know how to talk to Carol Kelly
doesn't know if anyone is talking to her
and negan just wants to talk his way out
of everything he's all kind of served
the key events of episode 5 and it's
very much centered around these
characters and what they are going
through we opened with Kelly who is
pretty much trying to prove to herself
that she is a value and can overcome her
rapidly deteriorating hearing and it's
quite easy to sympathize with the
character I'm sure we've all had
setbacks in our lives where we've done
something to prove that we are actually
better than our worst aspects and it
sucks seeing the character just hit with
blowback after blow back becoming
rapidly aware that she probably isn't
cut out for this life the intro has is
questioning what will happen to her and
this is murdered and negan with him out
on the run we are left asking who set
him free where will he go next and where
the heck ins is this leather jacket yes
I said heck ins this isn't a PG video we
go hard negan's escape couldn't have
come at a worse time either mainly
because the Christmas sales unleaded
jackets haven't started yet and also
because the camp is at its lowest point
in the wake of last week's horde attack
a lot of supplies have been stolen and
the survivors of Alexandria pretty much
have to stay back and put their own home
in order before going after everyone's
favorite baseball star Meighan joined by
Rondon his parole officer it's revealed
to be the one that released the villain
because his father idolized him and now
he does to those who read the comics
will have seen this coming a mile off
and similar to the character in the
source material depiction Brandon just
wants his hero to return it differs
slightly from the comic books as in that
Brandon's father was killed by Rick in
self-defense so he unleashed negan in
order to start a war between the
whisperers and the camp in negan he
slept the beast out of the cage and now
he initially doesn't make his motives
clear it becomes apparent that he is
trying to get the character to reveal
his true side gifting him his infamous
leather jacket and Lucille which is
probably still covered in Glenn's brains
Brandon really acts as the devil on
Nikken shoulder this episode and
throughout he constantly tempts the
character it's an awesome aesthetic in
watching him shout damn classic negan is
hilarious now I have been saying that
this episode would be something special
for a while and it didn't disappoint
watching old nags get back into the
swing of things pun intended is
brilliant and it really makes me want to
see a lot more focus on the character in
the future he meets two more survivors
out on the road a mother and a son that
Brandon tries to use in order to
manipulate negan into remembering that
people should be used in whatever way
possible to live another day this kind
of plays into the end and it shows that
though negan may not be the old one
he still has a dark side in other parts
of the camp daryl is out and about with
connie on the hunt for Kellie and it's
clear that she's run into some trouble
and after the cliffhanger opening her
fate comes into question throughout the
episode I'm glad that The Walking Dead
is really at a point now where every
character's death feels like it could
come at any moment and this manhunt or
sorry woman hunt is a nice little
subplot for the main action of the
episode else where we learn that though
The Walking Dead whisperers and so on
still live the group also has to deal
with the real-life diseases that often
come with being a human this comes in
the form of Zeke who though we don't
know for certain has appeared to have
developed a Tyrod cancer natural
diseases and things like this are
something that I've always wondered
about in this world and it's great that
we finally are at a point where they are
tackling it and it reminds us of just
how screwed
probably is there are no doctors no
surgeons and no chemo so if Zeke's
diagnosis is indeed correct then he's
probably fresh out of luck in other
parts of the camp Earl is spouting off
his conspiracy theories about how alpha
attacked the camp the grassy knoll and
how the moon is made of cheese
turns out he's right though and we do
get confirmation in this episode that
the whisperers have indeed been trying
to off the group alpha clearly wants to
wear the survivors down but the
whisperers and I guess the audience are
questioning why she doesn't just unleash
a massive hoard the show does what it
has to do and answers this subtly by
having alpha kill at a Center for
questioning her leadership and to me
this cements that the reason she refuses
to do it is because of Lydia Alva has
the means to kill them outright but deep
down she knows that she will also kill
her daughter in the process and as much
as she claims she wants to do it she
clearly doesn't maybe she should just
sneak into the camp one night and do
some nut tapping remember don't aim too
high gamma is clearly struggling with
her strategy too and after Aeryn helps
her it hints that she might be the weak
link in the chain that ends up making
its snap later in the episode we learned
that Alpha wants to use gamma as bait to
draw Eren out and getting in in the camp
and it's gonna be interesting to see how
this develops Kelly is found asleep in
the woods and it's revealed that she
took the supplies and this raises the
distrust through this Hawk we discovered
that Magnus spent her time in jail due
to her going Batman on a Manor ended up
doing no time for assaulting her young
cousin and Yumiko defended her because
she believed that Magna was innocent
turns out she wasn't and it's a nice
reveal that shows she is one of the good
guys deep down and also highlights the
parallels of the current world in the
old one this was a crime but here now we
know just how low people can sink it's
not that bad what is bad though is that
Brandon kills the mother and son that he
and negan discovered in order to try and
set off the character he gets his wish
but not in the way that he expected and
negan finally unleashes smashing his
head in with a rock
I guess she should never meet your
heroes we watch as the hero or Belen
well here oh yeah look he's the best
part of the show heads into Whisperer
territory he says what's a fella gotta
do to get eaten
and it's clear that the old negan is
back and who knows he might even be here
to stay as he starts taking down walkers
like it's nothing he's grabbed by beta
and it looks like the two are going to
faceoff which is when we cut two credits
now going forward
it's clear that negan will indeed be
joining up with the whisperers and
integrating with their camp I'm gonna go
into some heavy comic spoilers here that
could happen in the show so if you don't
want to know anything about one of the
deaths of the big villains then I highly
suggest that you turn off now if he's
still here then thanks for sticking
around but in the comics negan does
indeed manage to meld in with the
whisperers and he pretends to love alpha
in order to get really closer to her
through their conversations he realizes
that she is still harboring emotions for
not only Lydia but people in general and
alpha breaks down and cries and this
gives negan the perfect opportunity to
slit her throat killing her in the
process last week I did say that I
didn't think that the show was gonna go
this way but actually now we've kind of
seen the way things are progressing with
the death of Brandon negan approaching
the camp and so on actually think that
they probably will end up doing this
there are three episodes left before
going to the big midseason break and
this could mean that negan gets rooted
in the camp for the next episode begins
to make his play in the following one
and then the finale ends with him
killing the character it's a really
exciting prospect and it could and this
half of the season on a big big moment
The Walking Dead this year has really
hit its stride again in my opinion and
this has been one of the best seasons
that we've had in a long time there
wasn't much competition but this has
been a really good entry that feels like
a great character piece for negan and
the survivors going forward it looks
like Carol is gonna arm up to and who
knows maybe she will be the one that
gets out while to negan causes a
distraction either way I do think that
the home run hitter is doing this all as
a plan to show that he's worth bringing
back to Alexandria and killing our firm
maybe his only way home now obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
episode and what you want to see down
the line comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up make sure you
check out my full breakdown of the
series so far which would be linked at
the end
we went over everything you need to know
so if you just want to catch up or need
a quick reminder then this is the
channel for you you want to come chat to
me after the video then make sure you
follow me on twitter at definition
whitey or head over to my discord server
which you'll be linked in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with all the
latest videos on the channel so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
the marble phase 3 part 1 boxer and
blu-ray which contains Civil War Doctor
Strange homecoming Ragnarok and more and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is like the video make
sure that you subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the episode
in the comments section below but when
it's gonna be chosen on the 15th of
November and the Cell be shipped out
from then - if it gets the prize so best
of luck to everyone who takes part this
is the channel for people who are never
missing television so if that's the kind
of thing you like you need to subscribe
to definition thanks again for taking
the time to watch this you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
you
[Music]